ces auto dérision c'est patrick bruel
ouais toi et booder meurent en même
temps ouais arrive là où on arrive à
l'enfer on a fait des gros france est
bon parce qu elle est arrivée la
première fois la première porte à sion
il ya une meuf et clan t il la regarde
elle l entend une voix patrick bruel
pour les délits que vous avez commis sur
terre
vous allez rester avec cette femme toute
votre vie les qualités la meuf elle
éclate et alain bras dans le dos à une
oreille y range d'importer ce faire
deuxième tentative de vol un porte à
porte s ouvre une femme mais encore plus
à l'aise nous ici têtes éclatées cyril
hanouna pour toutes les bêtises que vous
avez fait dans votre vie vous allez
passer l'éternité avec cette femme
tu rentres à porter cela moi j'arrive la
porte à sion c'est kim kardashian voilà
comment auf et la voix elle dit qu une
carnation
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
un leader dans
mais qui veut faire plaisir à sa femme
1 quelle enceinte de triplés j'achète un
perroquet de huit mois et dit viens je
t'emmène avec moi à la chasse c'est le
huitième mois ça va te faire du bien la
forme et les histoires il paraît tout y
est mais qui châtient chasse la perdrix
ça me paraît une perdrix qui arrive qui
bouge mieux c'est de tarbes on me tire
irak la perdrix touche sa femme mais
comme un fou du l'emmène aux urgences et
tout bon il sauve les bébés il sauve la
femme et le chirurgien ludique août
comme tu as tiré du plomb il va y avoir
du reste chez les enfants mais quand ils
vont grandir vos dans leurs selles et où
ils vont lâcher le truc t'inquiète pas
huit ans plus tard le premier arrive au
courrier de sa mère mme hama j'ai pas
mal qui va obliger tout wallet j'ai fait
j'ai iej c'est le plan qui est sorti
avec des métiers pas à lui raconte toute
l'histoire on était barrée des histoires
club
le deuxième à quoi immédiate aux
toilettes je fais caca la vie du plan
dimanche l'ex quitté tbb radlight
puisque quoi le troisième il arrive de
loi serbe a été aux toilettes
j'ai pété bethune shirt
[Applaudissements]
dans un hôpital psychiatrique voilà
c'est l'examen de fin d'année donc
quelle est l'opinion docteur qui ramène
trois fous il demande aux premiers fous
il dit
trois fois quatre offres mercredi il
appelle le deuxième il y 3 x 4
dia 1485 merlus pas possible la preuve
le troisième 3.4 direct du 10 12 10 mais
comment tu as fait dit j'ai divisé
mercredi par 1404 fait pas ce sarko un
bon camp mais il est plus là on peut pas
voir de problème moder derradji j'avais
speedway il nous regarde bonjour sous
l'ère sarkozy les présidents bon effet
un banquet des ministres ouais il
appelle tous les ministres ils ont dit
ça va pas la france va mal et leur fait
un repas de choix pour discuter de
comment on va faire il est en même mangé
dans un grand restaurant parisien
maintenant les couverts ils sont tous en
mort puisse jamais vu ça des ministres a
compris le truc là claude guéant qui
voit une cuillère en ans et se dit
j'aime lâcherez comme ça je vais
l'emmener chez moi manuel vincent fassi
voit ce truc bon s'ils vont jouer
quoique nuit il fait ça et ce à quoi le
vote jobs est un voleur toit et des non
choix magicien jamais là va sortir chez
lyon
[Applaudissements]
simon bénichou rachel docteur des
docteurs faut que je vous parle je
m'attendais prenait rendez-vous faut que
je vous parle si urgent edit bon j du
monde la dhr à sanaa tandis de foot je
vous parle
mais bon alors qu'est-ce qui se passe il
écoute et à trois semaines je rentrais
chez moi j'ai vu ma femme au lit avec un
autre homme
ça va énerver j'ai été dans mon art moi
j'ai pris mon fusil à pompe et je me
suis dit fais allumer tous les deux mais
ma femme a regardé comme a dit cherry
c'est toi que j'ai alors j'ai accusé le
coup jeudi elle c'est pas grave on va
boire un café tous les trois obtenu quoi
vous m'arrêtez pour me raconter ça moi
je vais trop vite à klaxons
attendez ce n'est pas fini
la semaine dernière je rentre chez moi
je vois ma femme avec deux hommes
sérieux ça bon ben j'ai vous l'a dit je
sais pas j'étais dans mon armoire j'ai
pris mon visa paul vi je vais allumer
tous les trois et ma femme a regardé et
m'a dit mettez quelques pas c'est toi
que j'aime
alors j'ai accusé le coup il dira
novembre à café tous les clubs et du
baiia avant-hier je rentre chez moi il a
5 mais normaux les docteurs et des
aloses est allé chercher votre fusil
vous avez charger votre femme vous à
regarder c'est toi qui êtes mais c'est
quoi votre question je vous pose la
question est ce que à la longue le café
c'est pas bon pour moi
[Applaudissements]